unemployment fraud is a major problem
here in nevada getting information about
it is a challenge the i-team's vanessa
murphy searched for information and
answers and joins us now live with more
on what she found vanessa
brian while many nevadans need their
unemployment money
fraudsters are stealing it and dieter is
releasing
few details about this major problem
my operations director opened the mail
and it was a
filed unemployment application
with my name on it this is the document
debbie ritchie received she's the ceo of
body spa group
did you ever file for unemployment
absolutely not
absolutely not it's my company she says
she didn't receive
unemployment money either they had to
have had my
my social security number and knew where
i worked she called the department of
employment training
and rehabilitation or dieter to report
fraud
ring ring ring ring she says she hasn't
been able to reach
anyone it's alarming because if this
is happening what else is happening the
i-team reached out to dieter
and his spokeswoman said fraud can be
reported on the website claims will be
investigated by staff
and eater may or may not follow up to
get more information
richie's director of operations for the
salon group describes the website as
confusing
it's crazy i don't know what's happening
nothing's making sense anymore so how
many unemployment claims are believed to
be fraudulent
in a letter asking the u.s inspector
general for an investigation into deter
republican state leaders wrote that
deter recently reported
up to 185 thousand possibly fraudulent
jobless claims
costing the state millions of taxpayer
dollars
when the i-team asked deter and the
governor's office for more information
details were not provided so we reached
out to local communities
because while information is being
stolen from workers at private
businesses
like ritchie's public employee info is
also being stolen clark county reports
203
employees victimized the city of las
vegas reports 50 fraudulent claims
henderson reports 100 for march alone
north las vegas reports 74 and boulder
city
45. the i-team has also learned
information has been stolen from at
least
17 metro employees it just seems like
there's no control anymore
of anything richie says she contacted
the credit bureaus and she's keeping a
close eye on her bank accounts
number one concern is to stay safe but
second with all the fraud going on it's
just you really got to pay attention to
what you get in the mail
ritchie's next move is to contact the
attorney general's office which is
accepting complaints there is a task
force for covid 19 related crimes like
unemployment fraud but sources tell me
there is some confusion
about which agencies are investigating
this
for example metro does not have access
to deter systems
and their investigators have not been
provided the number of fraudulent claims
we do know metro's digital forensic
investigators
are working with dieter though to
investigate that metro
employee fraud we're listening there
about the investigations and looking
into it have there actually been any
arrests
brian we have not heard about many but i
can tell you
in june a las vegas woman was arrested
after the feds say
she used 40 stolen identities to collect
170 000 in
unemployment money look i know that is
frustrating for our viewers to hear
since so many of them are waiting for
their unemployment money
we do have some information at
eightnewsnow.com
on how to protect yourself some
resources there back